Oh
boom-boom-boom [ __ ] it move on
how's it going guys I already know what
you're gonna say look at my haircut it's
a bowl cut k-pop star blah blah blah
blah I haven't had the time to get my
hair cut
[ __ ] you but as you guys know if you
haven't seen it already
I shot a fake soju commercial on my
channel not too long ago
foolish oh so you guys know my channel
mostly my channel really consists of
blogs but every now then I put out
sketches and shorts because you know
that's really where my passion lives
also my sketches and shorts they
generally cost a lot more money to do my
vlogs though you know I'm cheap y'all
want to support me keep watching these
videos that maybe you get more sketches
[ __ ] [ __ ] a free and of course like
another reason why I don't put out too
much is because I think that I
scrutinize my stuff a lot and I and I
don't want to put out anything just for
the sake of putting it out but shooting
this fake commercial slash short film
was really fun I got to work with this
girl named Hannah
yeah yeah big shout out to Hannah Jen if
you guys want to give her follow go to
her Instagram follower and check her out
on maybe some of more of my videos if we
do more projects
cuz I'm hit you up girl holding the pole
head white onion rock strawberry
chocolate O'Neal politan this video was
also shot and edited and co-directed by
this do Jeon you guys may know him from
the Nike Basketball commercial
and also the Korean Nike just do a
commercial yeah obviously when I can put
these sketches in short films there's
always this twist at the end and funny
enough which you guys may or may not
know a lot of it has to do with true
stories about my life so you know that
pubic hair see he put him we just got
done filming the the pubic hair scene
Hanna I do like you
it's very curly but that twist Hetty had
your joke was actually something that
was very real my mom used to tell me
when I was kid if I'd like too much that
I was gonna go pubes on my balls I'm not
sure if that's a Korean saying I need
some creepy people to verify this but
shooting this sketch was really
difficult because we had to shoot a
majority of this at 2:00 a.m. all the
way to about 7 a.m. so it's 2 a.m. we're
out here at a local put John in
Koreatown this is one of our last shots
that we're doing we'll probably gonna
end around 5 a.m. but this is the only
time that you could really shoot at this
hour because every other time there's a
lot of noise and we cannot knows when
we're shooting the [ __ ] so you know this
is what we got to do that's [ __ ] Jay
over there
J just found out he didn't have a penis
it was pretty surprised I think the
worst or the weirdest part of the night
was when we were shooting there was a
very loud boom so evidently we were
shooting and we've heard spoken loud
boom and it turns out Eric's car got hit
by some random dude it's just about the
worst person that should ever happen
because he has OCD so the moment he sees
a small scratch on his car he freaks the
[ __ ] out but now his whole axle is
absolutely obliterated
he's freaking the [ __ ] out and hopefully
they try to figure out what's going on
so [ __ ] sucks you what the funny [ __ ]
like I used to give a lot of people crap
on worldstar would England just record
disasters
well that [ __ ] wasn't me that
night we are at the scene of an accident
I know that I shouldn't be vlogging
during this [ __ ] and capitalize on other
people's misery but what I do for work
this [ __ ] drunk as hell and of
course you're a no David Choi the homie
came through for the part you know
actually prior to me asking him to do
this part of the sketch I thought he
could speak Korean extremely fluently
biggest because I always see him flying
to Korea but I realized that just could
you go to create doesn't mean you know
how to speak Korean Marshall told you
I'm John what would tip with it kill
this party came through so thank you
very much David I appreciate that
next time I'll give you a pauper's on
English you know I'm doing sketches and
short film that's honestly where my
passion lies and I understand that you
know money wise is not that great
because I lose a lot of money in doing
this because this [ __ ] cost a lot of
money however not everything is supposed
to be about cash in this world and I
can't do everything just to make a buck
because you know your passion starts to
die is it worthwhile for me do I make a
lot of money off of this now I don't but
it kind of keeps me sane but I do have a
question for you guys before I leave if
I need a Kickstarter to start a web
series would you guys support it
it's about to get crazy loud in here and
all the names bad a couple of things
they can bang your walls order up a
thing go here loud and clear scream my
name your legs all up in the air praise
to put my hands all over here we have J
on say hello everybody introduce
yourselves and I'm John nice